[Musik]
[Applaus]
erich 17 jahren polizist aus dem iran
transportiert
da wo ich auch anspruchsvollere variante
starter
waren
sie schließt jetzt polizeischule
das super
[Musik]
von der kinder- oder
visuell
der eshop community steht morgen kurz
wurde siebter im stau wird spears fersen
dennoch torschütze
gespielt wurde erzählte mitarbeiter vom
stahlwerte polizisten und geständige
frau als vermisst gemeldet wurde es
rentiert sie dass die vermisste jetzt
der weibliche person im rachen
identität des noni klar aber definitv
personen verstorben
manchmal süß aufgebot iserloh antwort
ja das super steinbach am hotel als auch
bearbeitet
identifikation
das ressort ist
steckt sich auch holz schwemmholz den
schnitt viel sein
der eshop die und sein kollege paul des
zahlt die termine konnten
rechtsmediziner in gleicher später
unterstützt vor der blick
kraftwerksmitarbeiter
die shop wie es seit 17 jahren polizist
aber mittlerweile hat es schon jetzt
kaum
wachsen und das ist eigentlich
wie bringt alle auf dem wissensstand
piquet offizieren wo ich der forensiker
und
rechtsmedizinerin
[Musik]
zwei
mal die gegangen von fünfte um rache
mitarbeiter von kraftwerk drachen anlage
nutzt aber geschafft und hat dann nur
wieder festgestellt
rechtsmedizinerin macht sich parat
mit der maschine wird normalerweise
streep mutter recht hat die gene ein
toter körper wo zum vorbereitete zerrt
klar wird
die identität grenz visuell mit
allergrößter wahrscheinlichkeit karriere
zusätzlich wird aber nur den ort
lockerbie
und biggi offizierin koordiniert die
weiteren schritt mit der staatsanwalt in
wo ist experte seltsamer kläre ab 6 uhr
mesz verbrechen den umfang oder einen
suizid only
hat jetzt der sensible
ford seine mit der picke offizier in
zugehörige und bringt die todesnachricht
[Musik]
polizeikorps das landschaft bereitet sie
nachwuchs oft abschlussprüfer der
polizeischule vor jetzt ausstehend diana
staehly und den landwirt richard chance
am mehrere samstagmorgen verschiedene
szenarien a model spiele und zu tiefen
einbruch diebstahl
red und rohstoffe mal wird das den sieg
schafft von porno stars die branche ist
gewachsen
gegenstand sind gewarnt worden
eine person eine lösung brachte
aber
morgen im
gebäudebestand eine
falsche variante starter war die
variante dass der schlag war das heißt
man würde einfacher kommission und rat
gegenstand wo wachsen könnte das mit
laptops oder frist kosten
veranschlagte skibicki kommt heißt das
derstandard.at schafft vor ort gefunden
die hand
jetzt wechselte instruktor seine rolle
er wird zum geschädigter
die unworte die entwicklung bringt die
hannah stehen denn andre stoss im
konzept
mit dem branchen
diana staehly verliert der laut die
fordern
einfach für alle parteien
vor jetzt da ich studieren
und zwar haben sie einen sitz weiter
stoff
autoknacker buch die absturzstelle
sie hatte denn wenn sie dargestellt hat
später zieht da sagt sie und zwar bis zu
zwei christliche instanz dann künftig
einmal pro minute unterschrift plötzlich
fällt ihnen auf dass sie wichtige spur
übersehen zum beispiel potenzielle
einbruchswerkzeug
wenn grobe schnitzer im stollen diese
schlug ihr nämlich durch dna spuren zum
täter führe
zieht für das fazit dass mir dann ein
darunter die schau ich vergesse gang das
ist schrecklich sie denn
aber damit sprachen sich am letzten grün
und nur einige maus eine gerechte
sache also die
versorgung sie ich mache definitiv liebe
sprechen michael toddenroth fordern
sind dass man gute wahl wie du erst
einmal luft nach oben wenn die letzte
koordiniert europa fand etwas bewusst
war was muss machen
strukturiert
sagte sie
wir sind gut vorbereitet jetzt werden
einer von gomel unterstützt und gefühle
spielen immer noch folgen dann tagt die
leistung bringen kann wie man das gerne
hat die
netzagentur sache und aber das gefühl
ist gut
die
generalprobe der stil mit danke
danke
de/shop wie seit zu bringen wurde
todesnachricht vom vormittag im nachgang
wirkt nachdenklich 100 nachtschicht
punkt
und hoch und der erste funkspruch ein
neuer fall
menschen mit einer neuen geschichte
ein alzheimer kranke mann ist leica
spazieren und nimmer euro
beziffert
es
ist
[Musik]
jetzt schon 1 2 prozent fahren dahinter
dem personenspürhunde später wo man zu
verteidigen kann wo der
unterführung wird man sich danach und
dann noch mal groß gegenstand von
gabriele münter nicht irgendeine bis
parat man muss der sache mit euch und
deine hits maschinerie ja also das was
man sich leider immer separat auf bei
der kita
schlank athletisch mittelmark oder
verschlanken
und hoffen
doch
tun der philipp strohm und sucht groß
gestand
wo tun die vierte in traurig kruska
gestein leadsänger grund über funk
nachricht dass der mauer im noch bis
kanton solothurn gefunden wurden ist wo
und wir
noch sagt schlimme stunden bringt
kantonspolizei solothurn der mann wie 3
es kommt oft vor dass natürlich lied
vermisst gemeldet war und umso schöner
wenn sie unmittelbar nachdem es mal
wieder fragen wir jetzt was du
volkswagen haben natürlich das ungute
gefühl wenn man im tagdienst nach dem
sieg im super-g und dann dieses
extrem oder die angst
es happy end kurz vor mitternacht
der interkantonalen polizeischule
hitzkirch es happy end gibt grund jetzt
aus
für diana staehly und ihr kollege vom
abschluss briefe genau zwei wochen lang
wird er das theoretische und praktische
busse testet
ja es ist berlin das schließe extrem das
mitfahren als gedacht
die praktische griffige machens zweite
teams sind ausgelost wurde probierte in
johanna stähli hat den solothurner
zurzeit büro
[Musik]
thema vor der heutige briefing erfordert
sie erst jetzt ziemlich alles rennen ob
es ein telegramm natürlich mehr aus
sondern
er liegt da würde ich sagen
soll
[Musik]
ein letzter blick auf checkliste diana
staehly muss versuche der rot die
vorteile zuliebe
dachten helfe
[Musik]
breiviks experte kontrolliert person
hollywood liebling dann geht's los
oder brüchige sind kameras erlaubt erst
nachher darf mal wieder
verfolgten und
wenig zu wenig zu ende gedacht
zwischenbilanz hat experten durch zucker
sonst was sie ob sie das was jetzt aus
einer ähnlichen oder ob sie das schloss
handlungsbogen zusammenhang seien und
die rechtliche würdigung eine form
der mittag ganzes geschafft
ja definitiv das vom inneren
note seit mit ihnen erst später
auf renoviert wird es jetzt ernst
der deutsche gegner mit einer prise sex
mit diesem konzept bringen klar und
wirtschaft
was einigermaßen büro der baselbieter
einander widrig macht die praktische
griffige mitte mit zucker
[Musik]
jetzt erfordert ihres traffics thema
das super bescheiden familie favoriten
ich habe versprochen die taten vom netz
gestellt was war die ddr
mittwoch dass er dick machen
[Musik]
so leitet das mädchen verstorben wenn
schließlich
alles klar beim namen
der
personen zufällig an einem
mehrfamilienhaus bitter für mich und da
gehört dass es ein zweiter stock
ludwig
verstanden
da sind während der briefe aufnahmen
erlaubt erst noch er bietet
[Musik]
verabschiedet euch vor eurer
prüfungsteile
gutmachen
es geht immer optimierungsmöglichkeiten
aber ich denke so ingo ist das so
abgelaufen mindest trainiert haben keine
unerwarteten und auch keine fokussieren
es bestanden hat und mit welcher note
alltag als polizist rennt dann später es
so aussehe
schon deswegen ist sie genau gestellt
nein gott wird sie
geladen
man muss schon alles klar was passiert
ist
damit überstieg
stehen gestellt sie haben sie eigentlich
wirklich
der pc mit stock und hut ist der vorgang
nicht gerade regnet
oder der bau der rampe und el hierro
velo flüchten
ok
das ist abgelaufen
plötzlich langsam spüren
ganz links ein um zu mir und das spiel
wurde ihren steuern
funktioniert über eine schlager
jetzt kann man das doch nicht anhalten
und viel verkehr herrscht
hinter mir
trotz
anhaltender spielen haben wir es
erfahren und
sicher mit welle flüchte für sichere
therapie shopping
das
tor vor
allem den nachfahren deren kontakte oder
sonova dass hier eine platzwunde und
bewohner von schimpansen vertröstet
also ich auch nicht umspielen
seinen kollegen was machen
sie wenn man da nicht eher
abgeschnitten damals einem
verkehrsunfall vom klassischen sinn es
ist ein kontakt sekunde der spiegel ist
showbiz kaputt
darüber diskutiert ob das sinn macht
der kann in der rassistischen
gesagt es ist alles
wieder anders
häuser ist passiert nicht
service ist man sich ja und jetzt kommts
anderer aus
wie vorher
das haus mit dem stimmvolk an der
dankerser zonen das thema war bis
passiert
vertreter von damit mache
ich mir jetzt
dass das kann man nicht verlangen
es wäre schön und man kann nicht
verlangen
machen wir weiter wenn man das schöne
tage
das ist der klassiker mobile stände
hitze des gefechts könnte hoch von der
einem anderen anschlag zeit und liebe
leben
muss man aber von um stabile und fräsen
von spaniens große problem
zentrale 50 28
der abstand oder unfall zwei richtig
pause zusammen gegen berlin ist auch
jeder über bright spielt wohl auch
kritisch
signalisation mit susanne alles messen
webber frei
zita motiv durch rufe im polizeiposten
fi
platz machen und wenn es nicht läuft
kann man bis heute zusammen dass er ein
viel wert man kann kameradschaft zu
pflegen
es sind jede zivilisation
dann besser mit der tätigkeit
unter den
absteigern co
jetzt zeigt blöd
die heiße phase im wahrsten sinne des
wortes
denn seit die fachliche kompetenz
zentren für ein polizist die soziale
kompetenzen aber an und nehmen wir sie
ein teamplayer sein
kollege braucht uns vertragen das
aussehen
[Musik]
wir hätten das spiel und auch später faz
abschlussprüfung bestanden hat diana
staehly untereinander wird riecht der
wird sich freuen
dass ich die ganze harte arbeit gelohnt
hat im endeffekt jetzt die auf das haben
wir geschafft und jetzt jetzt ist groß
und der leaf dritte schaden noch größer
sogar
drei sind durch oli andere wandert das
klingt jetzt als junger polizist
praktischer und schließe dies bildet ein
mit der eidgenössische plusbrief
bürger die träume
[Applaus]
ja jetzt die absolventinnen und
absolventen
sind viele große vorträge für mich ob
sie als polizistin aus politisch zu
hören sind unbestritten eine der
abwechslungsreichsten prüft wird die
absolventinnen und absolventen
ich gratulieren ganz herzlich zum
erfolgreichen abschluss von dem lehrgang
dabei an der ph können sie sich viel zu
verlieren
genauso wie die großen applaus
[Musik]
stiller kantonspolizei basel landschaft
jetzt rettet die blomberger
mit dem diplom fans jetzt die zweite
praktische ausbildungsphase im chor auf
die heimkehr und anderen absolventinnen
und absolventen selbst endlich ganz ganz
guten start und sehr erfolgreiches jahr
dazu viermal 50 urteil
[Applaus]
nein
[Musik]
die sind also komfort starken toni kroos
das feld der kommandant von politikers
landschaft
bestanden hat das schwierige jahr
speziell jahr viel spaß und defizite
hedia gesetze und denn allzu gekommen
koren jetzt gehen zu lassen eine
polizistin
[Musik]
zum
abschluss dankte nation
[Musik]
vorfreude ist riesig jetzt der
meilenstein geschafft haben jetzt ein
bistro und ein anderes wetter praktisch
ein praktikum eigentlich ab jetzt haut
mitverantwortlich und nochmals bildung
im hintergrund und ja jetzt hat sich der
fotos falls du noch mal richtig keine
schaffen und vor vollgeschosse ich freue
mich unglaublich
freude herrscht im
alltag wohl jetzt ob sie zur und
erwartet sie allerdings schwierig seite
kommandant
die plastik das kommen im moment
generell läuft gut
positiv soll bleibt aber dort ist das
nun erreicht und bestand hat im personal
dementsprechende sportlich relativ groß
bietet sich auch gut zum arbeiten von
einem jahr ist es immer so schön
gemischt die situation
herzlich willkommen zum heutigen tag in
halle spielen auch die npd situation mit
wohnhäuser der jonas thiele das
praxisjahr tsonga mit gottes erstmal auf
patrouille zusammen mit
theorie
müssen
der shop erinnert sich noch gut an
seinen ersten tag nach der polizeischule
und sich vom höchst und probiert aber
das
machen meine sie gingen auf patrouille
sondern lengerich
bildes material
und
checklisten
[Musik]
die aller stille ist jetzt nimm aus
spielern sondern anwärterin die letzte
stufe vor der vereidigung zur politik
stehen
rom sind unterwegs davon tiere ein anbau
nötig
dessen tore
das thema lernen
es ist einfach es geht gut 80 franken
aber
jetzt
habe man schon viele und paragrafen wird
sie schon bald aus dem effeff kennen
wichtig sei sie ihre intuition zu
vertrauen sei tief schockiert
dass man lernt in der polizei sondern
auch petra witte billig dass man die
strikte haltet was man grund tut man die
lehrer auch wirklich das buch bildet
verlieren es braucht viel wasser durch
irgendein bis das nächste mal gelohnt
dass wir die dynamik von vater staat
oder joseph deiss und den
dass das volk nicht
[Musik]
einander wittlich mit sind orte wo ein
polizist ich allerdings nicht importiert
sondern spaß gipfel ja so nett wie zum
stamm geht
[Musik]
die karriere der band jetzt in klima und
ist natürlich von vorteil weil bei mir
bist du scheen fehlers mit
nicht da im vorfeld für mich persönlich
noch nie so klar ist aber gut im umgang
mit menschen oder umgang mit problemen
die man es auch noch relativ oft trübe
unterhalt und ich versuche so viel wie
möglich mit mit sneijder sie dann
entsprechenden hoffentlich monaten
politisch wäre
politisch city und bibi und beruf mit
vielen chancen
hat bei der polizei
aufstiegsmöglichkeiten oder wenn die
idee wirklich was bewegen bei der
polizei und die strecke noch mal hinter
den rollstuhl sage ich ein ziel ich würd
gern isst karte oder gar die prävention
oder über strukturen
besteht je nach dem gezielt also
durcharbeiten und der die bringen und
das ist ein großer vorteil ist eine
organisation
wirklich nur ein vorteil von meiner
politik
und das hat sich die band aber das
weitermachen will bisher noch mal wird
die polizei durch eine andere frage
wagte kameradschaft ist er wirklich ein
begeisterter pfadfinder wurde das quad
ihm jetzt der polizei
geschnappt situation wo es einfach ohne
sichtliche ist wo das gefühl riesig aus
und dann muss einfach mit der frau wurde
am gleichen strang damit wieder damit
sie richtig gut damit
[Musik]
nando wir treffpunkt jetzt praxisjahr
wenn das problem erschienene bis der
ganze chor sprecher also es gibt die
denken wir
dass man muss sagen die neuen und die
ganze schlucken und das noch aus meiner
zeit also in der bisherige oder sowohl
finish das ist nicht okay dann spricht
so was nicht mache nicht gang nicht an
und sagen und kommt eine erfahrene
kollegen wie sie mein schaffen und gar
nicht gut da
würde ich vorschlagen dass man auch dem
odenwald
sein erster fall
einbruchdiebstahl
[Musik]
honig ist offensichtlich durchsucht
wurde
erstaunt die strafbank art of
forensic die bruchstelle und 60
behältnis wurde
kurz darauf habe ich und freuen sich und
fängt mit der spurensicherung
vielleicht herz
[Musik]
während ein anderer richter opfer
befragt
zwanziger vor sagt rick bewernick
hinterlassen
da habe ich sie mit dem schlossen sich
die einzige öffnung sie sind die xii
also sind sie so inne und so wie du sie
schon ihren öffentlichen dem sieger
wer die branche vorgegangen sind ist
klar du dir tür sind sie drohen jetzt
mit polizisten hoffe dass sie eine
verdeck sichere spuren zu der täter
führt dass die nummer für bücher mit
sehr unwahrscheinlich erklärt
berg
nachtschicht gott wieder
und sie wehrte die als verstärkung kohl
tritt
hinterkopf bringen sie hin
denn
ein lieferwagen mit lauter junge männer
aus polen ist am morgen um 3 auf
nebenstraßen durch basel wertet das ist
der polizei verdächtig forum werdet
jetzt alle durchsucht es könnte nämlich
sie dass das so genannte
kriminaltouristen sind
deshalb
ist auch grenze für waffen- drogen- oder
so stickig er gestand dass in der
famitsu
obwohl es alles akribisch durchsucht
findet nicht verdächtig
man muss sagt sie sehe jetzt zum schafe
tweets
wie der vietkong
ein opfer slicks wäre nie stand
miteinander wichtig
jetzt rund büroarbeit einem großen teil
von politik durch das erste fazit jetzt
hat es noch mal bestätigt das
politische im baselbiet wichtig und das
übliche mentalität geschafft wird und
das finde ich super und das macht man
freud also steffen die tiefe
weiter angriff
nach 17 jahren durfte boston beer der
straße seit der ifpi ball zischt sie
wirklich ein traum aber keine nicht
spurlos an verbiege
männer die in sceaux
aber spricht dass das den auch die
endspiele und wochenende laufsteg
das ist
nach 17 rennen andere situation erlaube
familie ist halt nicht
immer möglich
april 2002 geschafft der schicht und
also ich bin entspannt - wirkt eher
feminin ausbildung sind zivilisten
polizisten wurde jetzt tritt sie ihre
neue aufgabe im alltag mit immer neuen
manche nur ihre geschichte
und immer wieder der nächste fall beim
kv letztlich wieder andere und verdient
sich jedes mal in der geschichte
dahinter und was macht im allgemeinen
entspannung
[Musik]